[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la rupture
à quand une femme parle de rupture on
pense souvent la rupture amoureuse
moi j'en ai connu des ruptures des
bouleversante des douloureuses mais
nécessaires
mais la rupture dont je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui elle est un peu particulière
il ya près de quatre ans aujourd'hui
c'est mon utérus qui m'a quittée comme
ça du jour au lendemain sans prévenir il
est tombé malade et pour ne pas
m'entraîner dans sa chute
on me l'a enlevé comme ça du jour au
lendemain sans prévenir j'ai perdu mon
essentiel celui sur qui je comptais pour
réaliser mon rêve celui de devenir maman
comme ça du jour au lendemain j'ai dû
apprendre à vivre avec ou plutôt sans
et je suis devenu une autre et c'est
cette histoire là que je vais vous
raconter aujourd'hui
alors quand je dis que devenir maman
c'était c'était un rêve c'est pas tout à
fait exact en fait devenir vraiment pour
moi c'était une évidence une suite
logique de ma mère m'a eu très jeune
elle m'a eue à 19 ans et donc j'ai
toujours pensé que pour moi ce serait
pareil dans ma chambre je jouais souvent
la maman avec mes peluche avec mes
poupées
je leur faisais la classe gt une
maîtresse parfois une secrétaire mais
dans mon univers n'y avait pas super
héroïne fat princess
non il y avait toujours cette maman
celle que je voyais dans le poste à la
télévision toujours de bonne humeur avec
des enfants une cuillère en bois à la
main celle que la publicité vous vend
comme le graal comme la norme
s'il ne devient pas cette femme qui est
épanouie parce qu'elle est maman tu aura
raté ta vie
alors évidemment je ne le dit pas comme
ça je suis trop petit mais l'idée infuse
forcément j'étais une petite fille qui
était ni brillante ni mauvaise du genre
qui fait pas de miracle mais qui fait
pas de vagues non plus l'élève dont la
mention passable fricote assez
régulièrement avec le peut mieux faire
j'ai eu mon bac avec une mention assez
bien
mais pourquoi faire mieux puisque c'est
assez sachant que moi ma grande ambition
c'était
de fonder une famille d'avoir des
enfants un travail des amis s'il est à
la portée de tout le monde
j'allais forcément y arriver donc me
voilà partie sur le chemin que je me
suis tracé comme un bon petit soldat
je décroche un vrai métier normal dans
un bureau donc objectif travail tchèque
et j'ai une vie sociale complètement
épanouissante donc objectif amis
tchèques
je fais du théâtre aussi alors là
j'adore je m'éclate et en plus il paraît
que je suis doué alors je suis très très
flatté quand quand les gens à la fin du
spectacle viennent me voir en me disant
à la sabrina pourquoi est ce que tu en
feras pas ton métier mais là je suis
catégorique
la réponse est non je préfère que le
théâtre reste un plaisir reste une
passion et je préfère le confort de mon
vrai métier normal dans mon bureau qui
n'est pas aussi passionnant mais qui a
au moins le mérite de me faire vivre les
collections sympa ça y est je suis
officiellement installé dans ma zone de
confort il ne me reste plus qu'à trouver
un mari et à faire mon bébé comme tout
le monde j'ai 30 ans je je je suis
toujours salarié dans mon bureau avec
mon vrai métier normal j'ai mon nombre
d'amis qui s'étoffe juste mes semelles
sur les scènes de théâtre amateur et je
joue des femmes fortes des femmes
fragiles des duchesses des princesses
des [ __ ]
je pleure je ris en fait je je joue
l'intensité que je ne vis pas mais c'est
pas grave ma vie ordinaire me convient
très bien grâce à l'extraordinaire que
me procure la scène en revanche j'ai
toujours pas de mari et encore moins de
bébés mais bon c'est pas grave
à 30 ans tout est encore possible je
suis large
je gère j'ai 35 ans et là je sors d'une
relation où j'ai joué à la maman pendant
cinq ans c'était super mais ces enfants
n'étaient pas les miens
et le papa est catégorique il n'en veut
plus c'est la rupture c'est douloureux
mais c'est nécessaire si je veux pouvoir
réaliser mon rêve de gosse
autour de moi tout le monde se marie moi
je me débats ge mord pour rattraper le
bouquet de la mariée pour être la
prochaine sur la liste parce que j'y
crois dur comme fer
toutes mes amies font des enfants alors
moi je voudrais qu'on appelle maman mais
on m'appelle tata saab
c'est pas grave à 35 ans
rien n'est joué mais rien n'est perdu
l'aventuré continue
je gère sauf qu'à force de chercher un
géniteur plutôt qu'un amoureux et de le
laisser faire le destin
j'entame une traversée du désert
affectif sans le moindre oasis et puis
un jour j'ai presque 40 ans et toujours
pas d'enfant
pire j'ai toujours pas de mec merlas et
l'angoissent moi qui ai toujours voulu
me fondre dans la masse je me rends bien
compte que je suis pas comme tout le
monde
les copains s'inquiète alors depuis
socialement aussi c'est compliqué
et sinon tu es marié tu as des enfants
non pardon j'ai l'impression que ce
serait moins dérangeant si j'annonçais
que j'ai une maladie grave parce que
être célibataire sans enfant à 40 ans
c'est pas une maladie c'est juste
suspect est leur pire parce qu'à cette
époque j'ai deux chats ce qui me rend
encore plus pathétique je le vois bien
c'est à dire que la vieille fille qui va
finir seule bouffée par ses chats témoin
et puis donc je décide quand même de
d'aller voir mon gynéco pour faire un
peu le point pour faire un bilan
hormonal
et puis me dit on approuve en profiter
pour faire un frottis ok super bouger
jamais trop su à quoi ça servait mais il
paraît que c'est la procédure normale
donc moins normal ça me parle donc nous
voilà partis pour le frottis pour le
bilan les résultats du bilan ce sont pas
dingue et le frottis dit que j'ai des
lésions suspectes sur mon col de
l'utérus et qui va falloir en couper un
morceau est ce que je vais toujours
pouvoir avoir des enfants
c'est la première question qui sort de
ma bouche la réponse est oui j'ai pu
c'est plus une horloge biologique que
j'ai dans la tête c'est une bombe à
retardement
c'est viscéral moi aussi je veux je veux
avoir l'air d'une baleine échouée sur un
canapé moi aussi je veux prendre 27
kilos pendant ma grossesse pour ne
perdre que 4 le jour de l'accouchement
moi aussi je veux me cogner le petit
orteil dans le pied du lit à 4h du mat
pour aller préparer un biberon
moi aussi je veux je vais avoir envie
d'abandonner ma progéniture sur une aire
d'autoroute parce que j'en peux plus
parce que je suis crevée parce que je
dors pas et ne pas le faire parce que
parce que je suis sa maman voilà c'est
pas compliqué et puis un jour ça y est
je les hais les quarante ans toujours
rien aux grands maux les grands remèdes
je retourne voir mon gynéco pour avoir
son avis sur la congélation d'ovocytes
en attendant de trouver le papa il me
donne les infos je vais réfléchir
il en profite pour me faire un frottis
de contrôle
résultat les lésions persiste et il va
encore falloir me couper un bout de mon
col mais il ne garantit que tout sera
encore possible
il sait de quoi j'ai peur donc là bas je
garde la tête haute je donne le change
comme je peux je mise tout sur
l'autodérision jeux comptines je
continue à faire rire la galerie
dans la vie comme sur scène et dans une
des cours de théâtre je rencontre sophie
sophie qui devient très rapidement une
amie sophie et journalistes mais elle
écrit des sketches aussi elles m'ont
fait lire un jeu l'adorent et je décide
de jouer en public et elle adore le
public aussi et à ce moment là elle me
dit sabrina je veux écrire un spectacle
je me dis cette fille est folle
comment je fais moi pour jouer et pour
répéter un spectacle avec mon vrai
métier normal dans mon bureau qui me
prend 5 jours sur 7 9 heures par jour
mais bon
la proposition est tellement inattendu
vertigineuse et en tant que je peux pas
refuser donc donc on verra bien je vais
gérer
nous voilà parti à travailler sur sur un
spectacle sauf il écrit comme personne
claire une amie comédienne nous rejoint
pour s'occuper de la mise en scène les
idées fusent le thème les femmes de 40
ans qui n'ont pas encore d'enfant
classique mais efficace
on trouvera le titre plus tard et un
jour coup de fil du gynéco naisse un
message oui bonjour madame nani je vous
appelle parce que votre problème n'est
pas réglé et il faudrait que vous
passiez à mon cabinet le plus rapidement
possible dites-moi quand vous pouvez
venir votre heure sera la mienne là je
me dis un truc il ya un truc il va
falloir encore me couper bout le col
c'est ça qui va se passer
et puis mais le truc c'est que la force
de me couper le col je me retrouve avec
un super décolleté mais je vais plus
pouvoir faire d'enfant j'y vais
vos lésions précancéreuses persistante
de grade 3 atteignait la limitant de
cervicales sans qu'on puisse vraiment
préciser si elle dépassait aujourd'hui
c'est confirmé carcinome épidermoïde
peut différencier du col cela priori un
cancer à statte débutants mais il va
malgré tout falloir tout enlever alors
là je j'entends cancer j'entends tout
enlever je comprends rien je dis
d'accord il me tend un kleenex et une
dit mais rassurez vous je vais vous
envoyer chez un de mes confrères qui a
l'habitude de procéder à ce genre de
chirurgie et vous ne devriez pas avoir
trop de cicatrices grâce à la
coelioscopie
comment lui dire à ce moment très précis
que j'échangerais toutes les cicatrices
du monde contre la possibilité d'avoir
un enfant je sors de je sors de là
complètement abasourdi je vis
impuissante
cette rupture avec mon corps cette
rupture avec mon désir de maternité
cette fois ça y est je ne serai plus
jamais comme tout le monde et mais là je
ne suis plus à l'école donc je ne peux
pas mieux faire et je ne suis pas assez
bien
j'ai peur je ne gère plus rien
j'annonce la nouvelle à à claire et
sophie elles me disent est ce que tu
veux qu'on arrête
et là je leur dis non non non on va pas
arrêter on va trouver un autre fil rouge
pour le spectacle et on va parler de ce
qui m'arrive
parce que moi j'ai besoin de donner un
sens à tout ça j'ai besoin de donner un
sens à ce qui n'en a pas et ce spectacle
sur les femmes qui n'ont pas encore
d'enfant devient celui d'une femme qui
n'emportera jamais et tous les
personnages que je comptais incarner
prennent alors une autre dimension et on
décide qu'à défaut de devenir mère dans
la vraie vie je jouerai toutes celles
que je ne serai jamais mais leur
attention est hors de question de ne
parler que de maladies d'aller dans le
pathos non maintenant à la base
ce spectacle est un spectacle qui est
drôle avec des personnages mordant et
haut en couleur il n'y a absolument
aucune raison que ça change
on va se marrer ces marais utile alors
je vais vous épargner les détails
sordides des mois qui ont suivi mais
grosso modo je les ai passées les pattes
écarté façon l'origine du monde de
courbet tout ça pour être à l'origine
bien entendu de rien du tout donc on m'a
retiré l'utérus
on va remonter les ovaires je sais pas
trop
j'ai découvert les joies de la ménopause
bien avant toutes les copines j'ai
pleuré beaucoup mais dans ces moments là
j'ai une fois de plus pas voulu aller
dans le pathos pour tenir le coup et
j'ai puisé dans l'humour une force
herculéenne qui m'a été très utile pour
moi comme pour mon entourage puisque de
toute façon je vous le dis j'ai quand
même vécu des situations il valait mieux
rires j'ai aussi découvert ce mot
nullipares au gré des consultations et
des fiches de renseignements je n'étais
plus qu'une nullipares c'est à dire que
je n'avais pas accouché ce set horrible
mot dans lequel moi je n'entends que nul
ou nulle part ce mot qui résonne comme
une impasse
un constat d'échec être maire c'est ce
que la société avait prévu pour toi et
même cela tu n'en a pas été capable
cancer j'ai aussi dû apprivoiser ce mot
pour mieux comprendre le mien tout
connaître de l'ennemi pour mieux le
combattre et j'ai appris que le cancer
du col de l'utérus est l'un des rares
cancer que l'on peut dépister
grâce à des frottis réguliers et un test
spécifique et que 40% des femmes ne font
pas de frottis alors je ne juge pas
c'est humain pas de grossesse en cours
pas de vie sexuelle pas de problèmes
particuliers voire déjà ménopausée
à quoi ça sert d'aller voir un gynéco
bien aujourd'hui après des années
d'errance
j'ai honte mais j'ai enfin compris à
l'échelle gynéco
ça peut te sauver la peau il existe
aussi un vaccin depuis plus de dix ans
aujourd'hui qu'on administre une petite
fille et aux petits garçons à partir de
11 ans et jusqu'à 17 ans et ce vaccin
permet d'éradiquer le cancer du col de
l'utérus entre autres un vaccin contre
le cancer et on n'en parle pas plus je
cherche une association pour en savoir
plus et j'en trouve une
une seule image in l'initiative des
malades atteintes de cancers
gynécologiques
j'envoie un message pour parler de mon
spectacle et de mon envie de lier humour
et prévention la présidente me rappelle
dans les cinq minutes qui suis
enthousiasmé et elle salue mon audace et
mon courage de faire ce spectacle pour
raconter mon histoire
moi mon audace et mon courage moi la
moyenne passable qu'elle confirme les
cancers gynécologiques
on en parle trop peu tout ce qui relève
de l'intimité c'est tabou et ben moi je
vais en parler et pour m'engager encore
plus concrètement j'ai décidé qu'une
partie des bénéfices du spectacle iront
à cette association
l'écriture se termine les répétitions
s'enchaînent toutes nos mamans prennent
vie toutes plus borderline les unes que
les autres
ça y est j'ai trouvé une salle je vais
jouer trois mois au théâtre du guichet
montparnasse
je crois je réalise pas bien mais en
fait mais en fait mais il est là il est
là mon bébé je les fais c'est mon
spectacle
on a décidé de l'appeler ex utero parce
que on vient tous d'un utérus et parce
que moi c'est mon utérus qui est devenu
un axe alors voilà ça fait maintenant
presque quatre ans qu'on a rompu et moi
quatre ans qui m'a quitté et si je ne le
dis pas personne ne peut le savoir ça ne
se voit pas alors je dois encore me
justifier quand on me pose la question
je pense vraiment qu'il faudrait arrêter
de demander aux femmes qui n'ont pas
d'enfant pourquoi elles n'en ont pas
elles auront toutes toujours
une bonne raison mais laissez les vous
la dire elle même moi par exemple c'est
parce que j'ai eu un cancer et que j'ai
plus d'utérus sakal non mais parfois je
me dis que c'est peut-être grâce à ce
cancer que j'ai pu accoucher de moi même
aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai quitté mon vrai
métier normal j'ai quitté mon bureau
j'ai osé envoyer valser ma ma vie
normale contre l'autre l'exceptionnel je
suis comédienne alors c'est pas facile
tous les jours étant donné le contexte
mais je crois que je ne me suis jamais
autant senti à ma place si je vous ai
raconté cette histoire aujourd'hui c'est
pour pour partager un message d'espoir
parce que moi j'aurais aimé qu'on me
dise qu'être mère n'était pas la seule
façon d'être une femme épanouie il y en
a beaucoup d'autres
croyez moi et je voudrais dire aussi à
toutes ces nullipares qui ne l'ont pas
choisi que nous ne sommes pas nuls loin
de là et qu'il y à beaucoup d'autres
façons de s'accomplir que les drames de
la vie se recycle qu'on peut transformer
le malambô le drôle en utile que les
ruptures ne sont peut-être pas toujours
un hasard rompre c'est remettre sait se
réinventer en rompant avec mes faux rêve
j'ai rencontré ma vraie vie voilà je
vous remercie de m'avoir écouté et
surtout prenez soin de vous c'est
important
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]